Ah yes, my hair has been restored do a...oh
Ruffles hair for linguistic power :3  *
Ah yes, my hair has been restored to PERFECT 👌
pristine red, ignore the fact that my
blood or spoilers XD ignore the fact that
my scalp is still died blood-red, I had
to dip my entire head into the blood of
my enemies to get a proper thorough diy
that's the only way I know how to do it
so let's get back to a game where we are
about to die over and over repeatedly
and you guys don't have to worry about
making me a blabblabbla   was literally about
to say you guys don't have to worry
about me making any mistakes but I'm an
expert linguist everyone says to
themselves in hushed whispers late into
the night that mark is the greatest
language to ever lingle it's hope that's
what they say about me anytime I try to
talk good about myself and don't work
too good but I ain't gonna deny that
i'll press on
I'm the greatest that ever was in
something i don't know what yet i'm
still trying to find but I'm the
greatest maybe this game but probably
not so it's fine now okay so i was
informed by you lovely people in the
comments in the last game and you
probably told me about this before but
the code to get the ventilation back up
and running is in that like police
like who where am I now oh hi remember
what's going on
I fucked it!
I have fucked it!
(Good God Mark!)
I dont, Oh i remember that
But if i recall, i wasnt...
WHAT MARK?!?!
so what I'm gonna do is it's in that
police like preparation room that's
where the code is and i believe it's
randomly generated so it wouldn't be
exactly the same thing you guys have
seen before and I'm hoping that they are
docile right now and they're going to be
docile, (weard mark)  it's okay okay, its nothing
and a whole lot of dick I'm too brave
and too strong to be forwarded by the
such as you okay so they said in like
the bottom corner of something
there's like a code handsome man tell me
the code is like a cold some all right
there is 2516 ok that's the code right?
who!!! we got a code i don't know if it's
going to do anything 2516 let's not
forget that one but i need to rush over
to the ventilation thing and then I need
to rush over and get a card but I before
I die
we're gonna put in this code you've 2516
enter yes
oh please tell me that's going to fix it
all and i'm going to be able to seeeeee!!! okay
i'm assuming that did good right that do
proper and did that do good i think my
vision is restoring normal i mean i
still can't see anything in front of me
but goddamnit that fix the stupid things
i'm gonna be so happy
oh ok where are they
I need to go get the card from there
back their neck
they're back oh not your that pussy damn
pussycat that didn't work i didn't i
didn't nail that one that joke in land
did stick  (daber adobe babu live)
I that ain't good at a good i lost my
chance to get a chord
I'm, i,  i might as well die I might as
well die
oh, oh, my niblets,
they've been jibbled, 1677 on the man I'm
the man with the code,Bamo, Bada Bing Bada BOOM!, i got it, ok, now i got to
see who's got the card but who does have
the card ? but not you again so must be
Wolfie in the middle of this room here
which is probably gonna go bad for me
because he's probably gonna wake up
probably probably probably lot of
probabilities where did you go
why is he not here? why is he not here?
don't like phat ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
oh that's not good I hear a thumping
thump but I don't see a thumpy thump
worthy thumpa-ige, the ventilation should
be coming back so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna I'm gonna charge my new
daddy get under here cower like a BITCH! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
a little baby bitch boy (Baloon Boy) that's what i am!
call me that from now im gonna do
little exercises pump up muscles and
then get out there and punch him in the
gonads because that's all I know how to
do extreme gonads  punches if they got
balls ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
prepare to get destroyed, if they got
ovaries ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) well that's a bit
better protected but I'm still gonna go
for either one, im gonna fist em
oh yeah i forgot i needed to get a card
from the back of them
oh I have fucked myself hello hello hi
hello
haha, nope! hey 63, ah there he is, do you have it on the back your neck?
you DO! 4633 I got this, (git some shit)mmumm
(gibber)looks like its some key card for some door? lets go find it
4633 okay here we go
I'm THE man x4 ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
4633 ok now that we got that that's been
inputted incorrectly and that's gonna
drop the temperature down and then i'm
going to be able to see better and also
i remember there being some dialogue
about here so maybe this was necessary
going through here and just see
ya, SEE? the car just went away so that means
it was supposed to be used there if it
went away afterwards so now imagine it's
just a survival game right just try to
stay alive
yeah okay yeah this is where I wanted to
go now what the hell am I supposed to do
because I got the key card from the back
of one of them i tried it on the front
door it went out of my inventory so i
gotta imagine that something else is
going to trigger here but i'm not
entirely sure whatt ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
A47 stuck under this desk, no end in sight,
animatronic still have not run out of
batteries
it seems they feed off my fear and I've
got a lot of that what I don't have a
lot of his food, shelter, and a place to
go to the bathroom, I have completely
filled the underneath of this desk with
my feces
it's very disgusting, please help me,
where do they keep going
oh hey whoa they white they shut down
again that's just what they're doing
what is there like another key card that
I need to find am I supposed to find the
right key card is oh my god is that the
idea here is that the idea
ok
What the Fuck are u doing? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
WHoo!!,,,, Hii ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
whoa how long were you there i was
listening the heart beat for a long time
Whyyy?? i dont get this!? X2
What The FUCK??!!, do i do NOW???!!
am i boned? am i bonederone! is this me dead? are u shutdown? are u for
realsies because that's a good question
i'm not sure what I should do
heigh-ho (X3) ok, so, bro,
can you?
you're not active, okay, so I'm gonna take
this, i'm gonna go away,
Oh GOD DAMN ITT!! fucking cock!!! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
SO!! here's my strategy,
this is what I'm gonna do, you guys wanna
see me do it, because I got a lot of time
and I'm gonna make sure that this gets
done right
I have a feeling they're going to go
through routine shutdown patterns so
what happens is the first key cards
gonna be wrong and I'm gonna find
another key card on the back of them for
some reason that I'm gonna find another
and I need to keep going and trying
until it works correctly, i guess??!!
whoo nellie
hello, hi friend, how are you doing? nice
bulge, nice Fupa, that's a quality foop
you got the card
he's got the card, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) he's got the card!
that's good
ah shut down yes ok I was right
(it's the key card for some door) huh!
haven't I been through this before ok so
try this one
I bet it's not gonna be the 100 yes yes
maybe
oh no no
yeah, yay? i just kind of stuck my face
into the corner by the door that's not
exactly escaping, but I'll take it
there you go! WE DID IT ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
yeah!!! everybody! celebrate, dance in the
streets, I finally did it and i only made
marginal amount of help i was actually
very close in the last episode but I
didn't even know that! but there we GO!
that is Case Animatronics, this game took
me way too long to beat i know that, i am
sorry about that, that is my fault my
fault alone, I let this video get away
from me, and transitioning into this new
recording space and all that jazz and
all the stuff that happened with packs
and traveling, this one kind of fell
through the cracks and I apologize for
that i meant to get this done in like a
week
it took me a month! but either way it is
done i hope you guys enjoyed it was an
interesting challenge
I feel like there could have been a lot
more substance to it, because at the end
of the day you think about it you just
want around the very same small level
and a lot of it gets a little repetitive
after a while, and the threat of the
enemy is always constant in the game
which is, you know, I think what you got
to be careful with constant threat not
escalating threat
I mean more animatronics that are
functionally the same isn't always
escalating the threat, it's just making
the same threat multiplied, which can
still get boring, so I feel like there
could have been new and interesting ways
that this could have come at you, but it
was still a good job, so I can't say it's
too terrible, because he was actually a
well made game! well-put-together voice
acting was a little dull, but i will let
that go so, thank you everybody so much
Thank You! everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
BUH BYE!